you could say that he was so cool under
control you throw his movements yes oh
oh man it was beautiful it was if
anybody wanted to learn anything about
Bosnia time talk about the art of boxing
watch that fight hey everybody welcome
to a special episode of hotbox and I'm
Evan Britain and I'm Mike Tyson
like we've got a legend in here who led
to the name but we're gonna speak to the
one legend right yes yes absolutely
Sugar Ray Leonard welcome my brother
thank you so thank you so much for being
here I said I would do I would I'll be
here I was waiting a while today the day
after my birthday all right I'll have a
happy belated birthday
no 232 congratulations folks program
that is so beautiful you're not even at
your peak yet I know I just feel like
I'm coming to the peak of the mountain
here 32 man it's like psycho embryo yeah
it really is
I know and where does the time go as you
guys were saying as well to the ultimate
champions of the world here ray it's
great to have you I know we've been
trying to get you in here for a while
and we got it done that well I'm happy
man I I told Mike mini I guess years ago
I I want to say two weeks ago I really I
was waiting for a moment but I didn't
know this one this is a drag I beat
myself up to come today and I got my mom
I have my nerve in my shoulder hurts
from old training wounds and think I
gotta come in today and interested a
interested came and always no discipline
is doing what you hate to do but do it
like you love it
Oh we'll use it Mike that's what it is
that's what it is that's what it is yeah
but listen let's go back on the sugar
man yeah Marilyn yeah right now Palmer
pork that's more DC than Baltimore right
now that's dcpl yeah DC area born Ray
Charlie Carter the rho3 child huh named
after your mother's favorite singer
named oppa Pete game doe named after Ray
Charles ray child is very Robeson to
reach out that's true Wow my mother
named me have to Ray Charles because she
thought I had a future not NSYNC yeah
yeah he know little did she know Wow he
know amazing so how early on was it when
you realized boxing was in your heart in
your spirit and something that you had
to do it wasn't I was introduced to
boxing through my brother Roger of a big
brother Roger and I was not a
classically inclined I was not tall I
was not strong well strong it was but I
wasn't those other factors and my first
time I experienced boxing was in at 210
well actually was a number two boys club
in Washington DC I put the gloves on
this kid hit me in the nose and I said
that's it I took the gloves off
but it took took about I don't know
about 8 10 more years later that I put
those gloves on again and was like I
found boxing boxing found me and we
found each other was a natural thing you
know and I was I was a quiet kid
introverted kid shy boxing gave me a
whole different lightning box he made me
who I am today
hmm what was it when you came back to it
that you fell in love with it so much
and you say boxing found you you found
boxing and we found each other is it's a
very integral relationship wife from the
start it was like mano mano was like me
against the other guy you know and I
thought I could I could when I always
felt that could win huh no matter what
the circumstances were or who I was up
against I always felt that I could win
there was a way that was a way I could
win and it it changed my whole life
it made me walk a little more with my
chin up
it made me walk a little more with
feeling confident being positive street
fights maybe I had to street fights
maybe in my entire life because I never
walked up to anyone I never I never had
that that look at my eyes I want to beat
people up it was just that I want to to
to be the best I want to be special
makes sense it's interesting Mike you
always say what do you always say tough
guys don't do well and bounce no no only
the smartest win yeah the only one
because you're the smartest yeah a tough
guy that gonna do good he's got to talk
funny at the end of the day hmm tough
guys yeah me yeah it is I mean they call
it the sweet science
it is indeed the sweet sons I don't care
who you are who as you as you're about
before you know it exactly mine exactly
Nanga you knocked out before you know it
before you know it interesting you know
it humbles us all it humbles you on
boxing has given me such a life man yeah
I mean it enabled me to to buy a home
that's paid for for my parents before
they left this earth
it gave me respect it gave me a sense of
self it allowed me to
to be a part of life and help others and
then I'm a can go down I in fact I get
teary eyes when I think about what I've
received from a sport it was looked down
upon I don't think he gave you respect
gray I don't count greet you of you
didn't have respect for yourself boxing
couldn't give it to you no Mike it did
it gave me strength
it gave me confidence it it made me into
a person yeah believe that believe again
you have confidence but you're who you
are you were born that way to car you
had such respect even if you didn't know
what it was okay you had me there
you had no here I'm a god I mean I'm a
god
I was raised Baptist and I pray all the
time specially now where I am in my life
all the time pray every single day and
ice apprai when I was the amateur boxer
I should pray not to win but I prayed no
one got hurt really yeah I said pray no
one got hurt and that's why I keep
saying boxing gave me so so much man and
it sounds corny but you know what I
don't care you know I am Who I am
because of boxing I am Alive I'm here
doing this interview with you Mike
because a boxing I mean there were times
when I had things happen to me that that
I had to I had to deal with being
sexually abused by a coach who I
believed in who I trusted I don't know
why I brought that up but I'm glad I'm
able to bring that up because Mike I
Love You Man and we go through battles
in the ring in fact when I give speeches
I talk I use boxing as a metaphor
fighting as a metaphor because we are
fighters even outside the boxing ring we
get knocked down we needs a great corner
we have to do our own version of
roadwork
and you know I enjoy doing this because
at first back in the day your years ago
I would share tears I would cry when I
couldn't talk about this these subject
matters but I can talk about it now
because of where I am and who I am ray
you're very clear in your mind and how
you express yourself and how you
interact with others and what do you
credit that to your mental clarity I
attribute that to first of all god no
question about that
for me this is this is how this is my
own personal means of trying to explain
or articulate it has got me I was on a
brutal sport for 8 over 40 years and to
have come out somewhat unscathed it is
truly a dream come true a blessing I
mean I didn't I've done all those things
I'm from from the cocaine - I'm an
alcoholic I mean those things I couldn't
I would never say because I was trying
to take care of myself and being a
publicist but I talk about these things
because you know why because they help
other people hmm they help all the
people I did a book I wrote a book back
in 2011 think it was and I talked about
cell and sexual child abuse I talked
about being an alcoholic and the whole
thing things that would never tell
because I was Sugar Ray Leonard I was
the best and I was strong I was but
inferable but now I talk about these
things because I can help someone else
home you know question
no question Mike how you doing beautiful
that you can't be replacing your life we
all come to this place in our life and I
guess it comes to it have to do when I'm
mortality in some way do we want to know
do we do we really believe that we're
gonna see God after we die if he sees us
is he gonna be right there with what he
saw in my lifetime and I know that some
[ __ ] [ __ ] sometimes but when I see
you I don't see that I feel my see
somebody when I'm 12 years old so if I
will Friedle Benitez I was locked up
what was there in 70 what nine seven
nine yes I'm locked up so what I'm 13
years old
I'm locked up in juvenile I'm watching
the fight he wants the title but he
fighting in the math didn't know one
thing he he fighting the guy who was a
champion of the world at 17 and that
amateur professional so it needs
probably 21 now fighting fine you obey
and he I can't even talk
no my god I mean I love you man and I'm
and I support you
oh no this bite me so [ __ ] I saw you
[ __ ] to read I bet this is what about it
be you might not think it nobody's gonna
love you beautiful you see only once
can't - you know I am pretty inmortal to
me you know before you lose to macho it
didn't even affect me get that was until
now wasn't you I wasn't even cried an
Impala ain't that hate to [ __ ] their
daddy see uh I shouldn't be on it fight
fighters did to me look at my [ __ ] this
were fighting it for me this is my [ __ ]
you know my show
yes I am
yeah almost like I worship you I think
that we are northern USD you came back
dawn she was throwing punches and I'm an
exponent of the order fighting she was
throwing punches I've learned from the
master my master cuz my mum don't
bunches he was don't combinations in the
art of punches when you throw two
punches it felt like there were two but
they sound like [ __ ] one punch
I say you don't understand anybody hears
this understand all the fighters they
know what I'm saying he do two punches
that sound like one
you know how magnificent your speed have
to be for that that little that you
don't even know that about fighting do
you yeah even come to your mind make us
but me too much it sound like one the
ultimate knockout puncher hmm they
ultimate knockout punch
don't hit by that don't get hit
listen I'm a [ __ ] student in the
floor I know all the boy it's from for
Charlemagne Achilles the number one boy
of all warriors from near Alexander and
the pony I know the more I read the more
I eat the more I know the harder fight
that no thought of war that's all I was
studied that's why I'm Sophia that's
what he feared me when I was in the ring
cuz that's all my I was a Knightly
that's all I was born for the other
things of Gaunt it's empty I'm nothing
I'm working on spilling the art of
humbleness even me that's the reason why
I'm crying cuz I'm not that person no
more and I miss him there's sometimes I
feel like a [ __ ] because I don't wanna
I don't want that person to come out
comes out hell it's coming with him and
it's not funny at all sound cool it's
just he think I'm scared of him that's
that's you know it's like my life itself
I look back do I have any regrets let me
I'm asked that question all the time do
I have any regrets
and I do innocence but then again I'm
saying I wouldn't be Who I am today if
those things didn't occur those things
didn't happen to me I've become a better
father a better husband a better friend
life they say the old thing life is what
you make it there's so true life is
indeed what you make it and and when you
give it all give it all yourself
beautifully brings up different man
sorry it's all about it's all but it's
all about what's inside of you how you
feel you know yeah and that's why I live
the life that I live now because um you
knew me 20 years ago you're gonna be 20
years ago and that guy kind of dead now
you know but that wasn't easy you know
that guy didn't want to leave either
wasn't even easy
he thought that he fought screamed and
cried to scratch all the way till he
died you know and I'm very grateful
that's why I'm really surprised um you
know and I'm like I can't be holding me
you did this too you can't you know you
can't be only me and you can get people
got inspiration I can do this [ __ ] he
come from where I come from a bad
neighborhood to him so people get killed
you know people died he he could make it
I can make it the end I'm saying I might
yes I never told you that leave all the
time I never told you that where you got
the chance brother my ego let me tell
them that my either one of them tell
them somebody who's crazier than me
Michael won't let me tell me that your
ego and you know and we all have one
some worse than others
but until you're able to to be able to
live with yourself within yourself and
when when you start to care for others I
mean again when people see me or I put
it this way when Mike or my little kids
when they were little Amish you say
little they saw boxing films of me
videos of me and everything and they
called me papa so they look at me
fighting and then they look at me and
say that's not the same guy because I
was so ferocious and I was so determined
in that ring but outside the ring I'm I
am Who I am you know I'm not I'm not
aggressive
I'm non confrontational you're unless
you're mess with my family my kids you
know they try to make your kids stronger
and better and this and that but you
know Nathalie had to walk their own
plane they have to walk their own Road
yeah so being a father is it's a
beautiful thing
absolutely being a father to me was the
big challenge to the challenge a
challenge and stuff look at my son
sometimes I see myself I see the me I
don't like I'm gonna kill it I don't
want to do to my son what he did to me
but maybe he handle it better than I do
it I doubt it
but maybe he does Who am I I'm not God
the thing was like with me be trying to
be a father a better father than I was
last year thought I was ten years ago
five years ago it's it is challenging
especially now because you know the
social media I mean the technology I
mean these kids are all kids are able to
learn more see more experience more and
and I try to instill but then again I'm
not as firm as my wife my wife is a lot
stronger than I am because she's just
say something and she means it
how kind of you know you know Daniel
it's um you know it's three o'clock in
the morning you should be sleep you know
but he's got great kids I'm not gonna
what I have great kids I just want to be
better I just want to be better and I I
criticize myself because I'm not a
better far
than the other guy or the other guy I
can't do that I shouldn't do that I know
that I killed the promise but they're
not of us they're gonna go places we can
never going after future
that's our Eagle one my kids to be like
us why would my kid wanna be like me
thinking about himself what they look at
it himself in the mirror thinking he's
the best and everything thinking
everyone wants something in his car why
would I will never make of Amelia
like me why would I want him to be like
that then be who he is but it's my ego I
want to control we want to control that
control yes security I'm scared he might
have milli 8 my name yeah and security
yeah he got a little life really what is
it might be gay in you and somebody
might be holding him back he might be
afraid to say because who my father
might be yeah
he might hurt himself I get it I get it
you know do it be who you are
I had to be Who I am even if you don't
like Who I am this is who I had to be to
be Who I am pretty much you know yeah
that's why I love my kids so much even
though when they bet they do ridiculous
things you just still have to love them
but they know I'm not an easy father the
[ __ ] would I miss a hard guy when it
comes to them yes that's just who I am
if there wasn't my kids you know but see
they tell me something my kids tell me
stuff because they know I'm not that I'm
not been aggressive I'm not that tough I
don't look that tough and you know I
don't they come to me and but then again
they also understand the fact that I
give them benefit of the doubt I'm I'm
not - I'm not firm maybe I should be but
this is who I am I you know my this is
who I am what does it mean that both you
guys ray you could start but what does
it mean to be a good father or to be a
better father this I I want to be a
better father me the best father that
there is no best father I'm gonna be a
better father and I try I pray and and I
hate talk to my friends I talked to I
don't
I talked to everyone and I you know like
one play I'm one I'm leaving town
tomorrow so on the plane
I know flew held that the passenger sit
beside me we're gonna talk about
something about the kids and I heed
their advice sometimes but life is what
you're making man in and I and it's a
different generation a different era fo
these young kids these kids these
teenagers you know I'm getting I'm
getting confused I'm confusing myself
because I'm trying to say the right
thing but then again I want to say the
real thing ya know that's what you think
and my situation on that my [ __ ] -
unless you have my father they
complained they got a millionaire father
with the great institutions they said my
father I wouldn't know I could never and
could never tell my father you know your
bad father you'd Esther that you know
cuz back in the day you know a belt
didn't feel good but my father did the
best he could and again look look at who
look or where I am today this is because
of my dad part of my dad and my mom my
mom was gonna include her my dad passed
away a lot last year at 95 mom's my
mom's incredible woman feisty but she
speaks your Pete she speaks her mind
almost too much yeah these are my man no
man and be a mean mother be a mean
[ __ ] that's it yeah you believe
that stuff but that's the skills they
had yeah I have different skills right
my skills are different my skills are
like you got to get your ass upstairs
okay if you don't want to go upstairs
just go to the house I bought you
all right that's me okay
I talked tough and stuff and I curse and
I do all that stuff but at the end of
the day yesterday
Princeton's called me today dad Harvard
called me today dad then I melt because
I'm proud of him you know that melt they
show me the education they got from
what's the school indicia what's that
varakin the American University got into
what I got that that did I melt did I
bite on something Oh
NYU again I graduated that I'm Milt hey
Dad I'm [ __ ] on Yale you sent me an
invitation to come visit the UM to bug
the ground
I melt they get what they want hmm you
know I didn't finish what sixth grade
seventh grade
hmm it's not a trip yeah I can reap
imagine I can't write that we wanna see
something funny about the greatest fight
little bit anything you go give me um
give me a [ __ ] one of those things
unemployment sheet let me let me um let
me uh answer one of those that's really
funny you really laugh but still people
I'm the greater than everything the
greatest thing I mean for many many
years it was always about me having
dinner at the house you know my mom
cooking no one can eat how I got there I
look I'm looking back I'm going back and
we wanted and we wanted my tape into my
head of things that occurred and how I
feel about them now ego
I have ego you have to have an ego to to
be successful you have to believe in
yourself yeah you know you just have
absolutely had that mindset I never
really never stepped into the ring I
mean although the odds were totally
against me I always believed I could win
there was some way I could win right
could you have done that without an ego
no no probably not no no because you
manufacture the ego to put out in front
of you this nice - what listening
if you watch him in Bonita sleep man you
guys just don't understand you watch him
and Benitez fight and one minute Benitez
is an arrogant mother and many of the
stands didn't look at him so I look at
you people you really think you're gonna
get this stuff and then he comes up he
walk from his corner he comes in Benitez
face and they start staring now and this
is the most intense stare down the
history of fighting at the time telling
like oh yeah yeah
listen I'm 13 I already met orgasm I
didn't you've never been with a girl the
ocean you know you think I blew you know
I don't I don't like I feel it now I
know what you're talking about
Oh [ __ ] I could I can look at right now
you remember that moment absolutely
mmm that fight with Benitez and then
with Roberto Duran yeah the first fight
when he beat me I remember looking at
him
I could heat me so hard they call a
model state Panther his hands a stone he
hit me so hard so many places I looked
Ron said who else is in the goddamn ring
I can right now
I because I'm talking about I can smell
his breath I can recreate that moment
laughing you would never know you could
say that it was so cool under control he
was doing this movement yes oh and man
it was beautiful it was if anybody
wanted to learn anything about Bosnia
time talk about the art of boxing watch
that fight but Benitez in him stuff and
then when he did when he dropping
innocent beneath this table what was
that the fourth round or something then
Benitez got up in his later he was he
was throwing those punches no no no no
my
damn all that fighting is in my blood I
love it so with the art of it why you'd
see it oh you'd feel I threw more
punches I never threw a Miss so many
punches in my entire career combined
that I missed with Bonita he was so
amazing
I lose it man
I was just learning about fighting baby
that's not maybe that this is one I want
to be able to port like that time in my
mind I was nothing this is my whole life
I wasn't my pen I was your guy yeah
there's a golden age there's a golden
age of boxing there's a lot of things
the the public and the fans are not
privy to the fact that after the banette
has fight I went to the hospital well I
was totally dehydrated I had to be the
punches you don't at all I just I was
tried to just and he was so slick and so
I might say we just it was a chess match
mmm a chess game you know hmm those were
those were the moments precious moments
that I can lose Rock - yeah it's locked
in
yeah it's in your DNA yes yeah no
question about knowing his breath
everybody for everybody he comes from so
deep dig down he'd be beating some ideas
cause there's poop oh the [ __ ]
flurries coming from nowhere for no way
that had no way
what was what was that group called the
fearsome foursome yeah and the horsemen
Kim Hagler Holmes Duran Duran yeah you
know I came out on the top of all that
stuff yeah I'm a top top top Tommy was
that Tommy was it let me tell you we
were quick by Tommy when I fought Tommy
Oh prot - Tommy was back in the day we
way in the morning of the fight so Tommy
was on the scale and he was I mean
emaciated I mean like this
[Laughter]
oh he was so weaker though
and then the night of the fight I'm in
the ring and Tommy's gonna ring up look
but that's not the same because he and
Tommy just blew up and knock out power
in both hands a fast tall and he was a
beast man
and anything you losing a son perfect
sound bite the perfect sound bite
you know he's Angela said that listen I
gotta go back I gotta go back to my my
antics on her that he's in the corner
his eyes closed
you're glowing and sun-grown he gets out
he hits Linnet overhand right through
the joined man sudden happen it look
like it miss Tommy right and Tommy goes
on and man he throws a bunch of
combinations about a blur and Tommy goes
down the sleeper went crazy absolutely
out of their mind they thought tommy was
gonna get it and they came from nowhere
yes palm to come down it was him you had
this you had to be there you know I was
on closed-circuit that must have been
amazing to be their life man I never
forgot it all those fights from 80s and
early eighties and stuff those guys
Duran Grail all these guys Benitez
man I never forgot those guys it was hot
I mean that fight it was like 100
degrees in the ring and back then before
what 15 rounds so 15 wins oh wow from 12
rounds to 15 although it seems like
three rounds this traditional those
that's what separate listen if they do
they do 60 punches around that was the
easy round yeah yeah I have a slow
walking around 50 punches a slow round
for them that's the round they took off
no really that was the rest room yeah
but and that was when Thomas showed me
that he
pika-pika bucks he can move my punch way
back yeah he got to a nice comedy boom
boom yeah
movement sorry Tommy they told everybody
about the fight I told everybody about
the fire I even examine I've called I'm
15 years old problem I was blind in the
game it's just that thing you know I'm
mad again like Mike said I was exhausted
both of us were exhausted but it takes
one punch to rock your opponent and then
all of a sudden that's when you bring
out that what the intestinal fortitude
that that heart that heart there's
nothing like that I love that people
underestimated I thought it was a
magnificent fight of you you're punching
precisely perfectionist oh I Luca Lully
oh that was beautiful punching fight
punching perfection yeah when I moved up
to dream middleweight said before yeah
he was he was I mean he didn't get
credit because he wasn't a household
name but he could find he was tough he
was tough man yeah but that I tell you
one of the most incredible matchups was
me and Hagler and people people were so
concerned about me rightfully so because
I've been out during and they heard
about my antics and you know hanging out
drinking and drugging and whatever but I
I I clean my system out for almost a
year and then a train I was in shape but
you don't know like what you don't know
what you had in the ring until you get
in there a year and the bell rung and I
and I was nervous I was shaking and I
said pop I said this should still work
because you don't you don't know because
one thing you really don't lose is speed
you may lead you may lose the the timing
be instant natural timing but you don't
pal your Papa Michaels don't have power
in office life mm-hm but it's just that
being able to punch or fight with
mm-hmm you lose that because we become
away from the ring after so many years
you become civilized mm-hmm you don't
because back in the day when I was fine
I didn't care about anything I didn't
care but I got hit my teeth good luck
whatever right but as I got older less
active getting into that ring isn't
isn't it's not an easy task because it's
all here you're all it's all here and it
makes a lot of sir yeah it's so tell me
huh tell me could listen to me I love to
know your ego work how did your ego feel
I'm afraid after you'd be haggle you
went to the joy through me went to you
I'll tell you in the shower and now pull
me coming out to the press conference
meet the people to afterparty
what was that like I'm God come on be
honest with us no I said that I said I
didn't tell was God but I said I'm the
man I'm the man I mean first of all
whether hey I was really conscious of
God now I'm talking about put yourself
with right that moment and that Rain Man
which is over at that moment you had to
be God
yes I was yeah it's a god but when he
thought about your demise
come on kill me you want easily not be
enemies be come on it wasn't my god are
you being heartless that's a humble even
know that no colorbox them I'm humbled
but I it was hard
Oh extremely looking at the fight you
won the round the rounds you want you
almost stood around then didn't you yeah
nah yeah you doing both punches and
stuff all right so let me tell you
looking very you wouldn't know okay
that's greatness right yeah making
something extremely hard looky look easy
but going to did right just go on the
distance with Marvin Hagler Marvelous
Marvin Hagler do you think wasn't gonna
knock him out no well you know the when
I finally came back
I don't know third fourth fifth round I
actually threw punches because I was
telling him and you and the commentators
never said it but I was sticking with
chin out nose all these things were just
trying to get inside of this head hmm
because during the let me tell you
something during the press conferences
we did I never similar not had allowed
this event I said hey you know what
people people they overlooked the fact
that Marvelous Marvin Hagler is a better
boxer he's also a better boxer than you
guys gave him credit for you look at him
as being a tough guy I said but he's a
better boxing and it's a shame that you
don't give him credit
no I feel cuz I thought he was gonna be
a daddy baby was gonna be different when
everybody was at BJ's walk you down
break you down yeah exactly a great
gonna do this [ __ ] you know I mean and I
mean when they made the whole world you
don't know what Hagler was back then hmm
Hagler was among a monster absolutely
Gary god i think somebody touched him on
arm and he smacked them ray what was
your what did you feel like in your
career was your greatest moment ever
because to Mike it sounds like from
Mike's perspective that was maybe one of
your greatest fights of all time but
maybe there was another moment in your
career where you felt in the zone in the
flow like and I ran fight out you're not
the fight that was just easy fight - it
appeared to be good okay yeah a second
one what the Duran the second fight
being I knew I could I could win but
what happened the first fight he took me
out my game plan he got into my head he
because he Roberto Duran cursed me out
he cuz my my life to do that from him
that's what I did I did
oh yeah man
I'll tell you and it gets got to me yeah
and I was a mother because we there was
a communication blockage we couldn't
communicate with each other so well cuz
he didn't speak English was a second
language yeah he didn't speak very good
English right yeah and so I try to be -
at his own game I say I might give him
by them Toto and I knew right from the
start but didn't didn't it didn't
register he hard enough serious enough
to say right you can't be him this way
you had a boxer hmm and by the time I
realized this was like 10th round never
around 12th round he hit me so many
times and so hard I I'm hurting right
now just thinking about it after the
fight did you say hey I could beat this
guy no I was gonna be time I know I was
going to retire cuz I'm a I got I mean
really doctor came to my room after the
fight and drew blood for my ears because
what happens when you brick those blood
vessels they hardened na to come what
color friends that's happened to me
today at the dream before her it doesn't
hurt ya I mean really I said I don't I
don't need this so I really I seriously
contemplated retirement again those give
ya avatar I got all the records for we
took but I went to Hawaii with my wife
and just trying to get away from it you
know different thing but I was running
on the street on the UH on the same
every morning and people say hey way you
can if he had boxing you would beat them
and I could I said I I call called Mike
Trainor say Mike I said I want to fight
to ran ASAP he's every all you on
vacation I said yeah but that doesn't
make a difference and we have a fight
scheduled the fight was scheduled five
months later well which is which was
pretty I'm president yeah yeah they
don't clear through that no yeah the
magnitude of big fights at all that
doesn't happen for a year or years yeah
that you showed the greed of people like
Don King
strike again
no that was my plan my plan would hurt
him there get him back in the ring as
soon as possible
and that's what happened you know that's
what took place you know who else was a
major major fight for me was dying alive
yeah I thought afraid to hear he heard
you every single time because they feel
damn amy-jo he didn't hurt me would
knock me down
he hurt me every other time he hit me I
mean I was almost out why did you want
to fight the guy another belt I made him
wait bill little guy Walter we win the
right heavyweight yeah it's just but I
really wish that crown right away proud
of the second day because I couldn't
fight those big guys man they they they
hit too hard I was significant
definitely I'm afraid that you have
about 150 135 yeah that's a lot of
fights I'm doing that you didn't count
the ones at the boot that I'm talking
what those fight that they don't count
know that all them together from your
first one to all of them yeah before you
even turn pro you know some guys got 500
400 meters from amateur I had Russian
stuff Pernell had a bunch of fight went
ahead
yeah pretty I'll have a great amateur
career yeah a lot of fights a lot of
fights
how many fight you had it as an amateur
I know 60 really yeah that's I had
around 150 street fights that's why I
didn't do too bad in boxing fight fight
fight fight you did this you did that
and we fight fight ray what is it like
you guys are you know two generations of
greatness and boxing you know what's it
like
to have watched might come up and then
to see him throughout his oh god what
you mister that was like a [ __ ]
comedy show oh and that wasn't here Mike
sorry I must've been like Oh seeing me
come on with me like what's wrong with
this guy no no Mike no no the first time
I saw you was every trip eh HBO fine I
will do it yeah and Mike walked into it
was walking to the ring and I looked at
him he didn't have socks on you he got
me a back to not wear socks with you
boxing shoes I mean it and then my head
like a do what I just said tell ya he
got in the ring and went Bell wrong the
intensity baby
Mike was went right at this man and the
left hook hook left hook was my I love
my left hooks and Mike was just going to
the body going to the head gone and and
it wasn't who he knocked out it was the
fastener he knocked these guys out there
was a amazingly Andy the audience the
proud the fans got went crazy and every
time he will fight it was always a
packed house and so why don't you talk
one did you turn I don't want you to
turn 84 85 are they team okay okay yeah
and then a myk's myk's myk's peeve was
it was unbelievable to and cuz speed is
power and he had that but you know by
Strauss was kind of a lost art and Mike
always go to distance to the body
brindle and bring those hands down and
just and now like the guys it was
something to watch yeah absolutely
thank you what was your best punch on
one your left hook was left Oh got more
guys on my left foot I withstood my
right hand was mmm you know I was so
pitiful getting more knockouts hmm
interesting
yeah is that interesting you can fight
in as I'm fighting spiritual is
unconsciousness I mean you're really
fighting you
you don't know what you do is just and
if this moment power factor that's
happening even though you you anticipate
don't listen but it's slowing when it's
flowing things happening this close yeah
what yeah somebody you might get your
head like that yeah absolutely
absolutely it sometime to floating yeah
your consciousness might be out of your
body you're watching yourself fight yeah
you know yeah I mean think about it and
what my sense is so accurate because if
I was fighting you I wouldn't have to
look at your body I'll just go get my
head yeah my has nowhere to go right you
were right
you're not thinking now Danny Boy
greendeath said knockout yeah anybody
greener Wow
holy moly dead I mean different Potomac
color you did it you do it it was yeah
yeah don't believe sedullus
I'm an idiot well he was dead it was
unconscious of capital center well
that's such a life of college out of
them that's such a great insight there
ray because you know fighting is such a
spiritual thing that usual body it's not
like you're saying I'm gonna punch I'm
gonna throw a left hook I'm gonna throw
right cross you know you're just like
your body is doing it you know you're
going straight to the place where you're
seeing you're visualizing making an
impact on another individual and then
your hands and your arms and your torso
and your legs are just the vehicle to go
to that place but before you put that
combination on another individual you
study that in the vid you know it's any
move right that's all you know this is
gonna it's this we got quarter absolute
i choreograph the fight in my head mmm
and break him down strong points weak
points height whatever like with Tommy
Hearns the first fight what was walking
around a ring I said who in this area
can beat Tommy Harris look I saw
Muhammad Ali I'm
and if you go back and watch the first
round of the fight I was boxing Tommy
just make them which upset him because
he wasn't so I use that incredible
punches yeah yeah yeah because what
happens
the speed it's just godly right you
can't imagine the guy didn't say he
didn't see it hmm you didn't see this
it's gone cuz well I heard him I threw
it just a barrage of punches and some of
a lot of some of them miss but they
would like grazing punches like crazy
damn literally they met you can't
explain yeah all precise wasn't getting
up wasn't getting up they know that
stuff
this is pinpoint accuracy it's
unbelievable yeah it is ray I want to
ask you about you know the movie the
fighter advice who is that about Mickey
Mickey walking what yeah no no no no
what's his last name
no yeah
but you fought his brother Declan you
thought him yes and he Mickey would his
yeah Mickey war Micky Ward Wow and dick
Eklund and you fought dick right yeah
and there's that famous scene let me
down right right he knocked you down and
then there's that whole thing of him
stepping over you or whatever it was and
then but more importantly what I want to
ask you about is and both of you guys I
think have great insight into this is
the the relationship of addiction and
fighters you know and because that movie
is all about you know dick Eklund really
struggled with drug addiction he's a
crackhead and you know had a lot of
issues with that and it's in it that
bled into his brother's life of [ __ ]
being just creating all kinds of chaos
and
brothers fighting career and both of you
guys I think have been very open and
honest about your addictions throughout
your life and what do you think it is
about the relationship between finding
yourself in a sport like boxing a
violent contact sport like boxing and
the mental mechanisms that contribute to
addictions whether it's drugs or alcohol
or sex or gambling whatever it might be
you know how do those things those
things seem to coexist frequently in
very successful fighters and athletes
you know in the NFL you see it all the
time as well you know I myself have
definitely had my issues with addiction
from drugs to sex etc and alcohol and I
know that my football career fed
directly into that and I'm curious what
your guys thoughts are on why are those
things you know happening at the same
time very frequently well first of all
it's accessible and it's there
especially the least yeah the access I
mean and for me it took place the drugs
and alcohol issues took place with me
when I was retired one of many times
because I wasn't happy I was as much as
I had I had low self-esteem I didn't
feel good about myself and when I tried
I was offered cocaine try it it was that
missing one of those missing ingredients
that I needed to feel better about
myself then alcohol became an issue
because alcohol and but to me alcohol
and cocaine mixed very well so good good
supplements good ingredients but I
nearly lost it I'm nearly
went over the bridge because if I did it
every single day but one friend of mine
James Anderson who was my secure my man
today James Anderson he said it's a ray
because he wasn't afraid to tell me
right from wrong
he said Bray you know what forget about
you the hell with you think about your
parents think about your kids and they
see you get locked up because you drunk
driving though you don't too much drugs
whatever he said hell with you look in
the mirror see who he fine and I looked
in the mirror that night later on that
night I cry like I cried like a baby
because I said that is not the person my
mother and father you know raised me to
be and I stopped the cocaine cocaine was
culture it just stopped to stop doing
cocaine it was the alcohol that that had
had me in his in his arms and it spit me
and its claws and I've been 15 years
sober you know and I again I see I
didn't talk about this I didn't I never
brought this up to anyone but again I
talk about this it happened to me sexual
abuse I talk about it now and I don't I
don't I don't cry I make sure to tear
but that's because I'm happy I'm happy
then and I and I talk about it because
even my speeches sometimes I'll bring it
up and I said what am i doing because
the place gets quiet but I feel okay now
um there's so much gratitude that I have
being an a again just overcoming some of
the biggest fights in my life and that
was the alcohol that was the drugs but
is it all man I mean I'm I'm not some
innocent kid Oh innocent guy I've done
it all but I broke away from it and
that's why I'm here
it's a good place to be a good place to
be you know we all go through that you
know when I was young coming up I grew
up out of enemy complex an enemy with me
yeah yeah you know complex
enemy with me everybody's mining my
fighters my fighters coaches trainers
coach then come talk to me I'll threaten
his coach his family man either all them
of my enemies if I see my father this
press conference this war and what was I
like there because my insecurity my
guilt my shame all that stuff made me a
savage and then that self-love so I
showed the back and I got an animal hmm
you know and then you go to that and you
um
you've known um you know in a different
way of life not saying that that's a bad
way like this is not my way of life
anymore you know it's not far from me
but it's just not how I want to conduct
myself anymore yeah it's so interesting
you said ray you know you were at this
place in your life where you had
everything and yet you had no
self-esteem
is that interesting oh no it's not
interesting well I mean the greatest
nation greatest warriors the greatest
Conqueror that the smallest low
self-esteem Napoleon Alexander the Great
mmm
that's ancient they're afraid of their
mother you know I can't leave all these
guys those of their mothers have to tell
them who they were their mamas boys
can't believe that Majan telling them
their mama's boy I believe okay look at
it look what they left to us over the
years that we think of them Mama's boys
to have the the sense of the power or
the will to talk about yourself in a in
a negative way laboratory is hard
derogatory it's it's it's it's hard and
it gets harder sometimes pending where
you are and success you don't want
people to know because people assume
you're weak you know oh you a bad guy or
bad person but I talk I speak on this
because I know what they do foot I mean
if I stayed on this rope on that road I
should say I stayed on that road I would
be here talking to you guys today
you know I wouldn't be here but we can't
stay on the road one wondering why we're
disappointed with this part of our
character look a lot of beautiful path
of our characteristics that we got I
might be this I might be that I might be
a criminal I might have done this and
that but look how great I am
look how beautiful I look look how many
great men i beaten my name is Sugar Ray
Leonard what but yeah all right I need a
coconut a beautiful you everybody they
came for that money see me they have to
say hi but that's that's really true it
what you know it's like my life I'm so
incredibly blessed and I like when I go
to my my meetings my my meetings and
sometimes I have people say I'm Kravitz
I'm Bassam so I have such gratitude and
I'm saying I could not I couldn't
understand that I leave have gratitude
hmm and the other day I was at a meeting
I said I have gratitude because it I
mean 15 13 years for me to say that 15
years and I I'm and I feel incredible
because I reciprocate I give back make a
difference I made an impact in the ring
I want to make the same or even a larger
impact I'll star the rate helping people
yeah
when you woke up this morning what were
some of the first thoughts that ran
through your head I'm alive you know and
not harsh but I just say that I just say
you know what
Kyra I remember sitting this is many
years ago I was it I was in being I woke
up hungover every just feel sick to my
just to my gut to my head everything was
hurting I looked I looked at TV which
was on and there was someone shooting
and I reached down grabbed my gun and I
shot back at it I shot Bootsie BIA it
sounds funny but it's not funny it's
reality I could have been down there I
could continue down that road and you
know is it shocking I should say well
yeah cuz I got made with her or a girl
no no it's not shocking it just it's a
stage it's just gets worse if you don't
wake up don't wake but there's guys like
that did you you know you can give them
the word you can give Aerosmith's that
word you know you can give a lot of
fighters there a lot of people dying
fighters good people with those are
mentalities of grandeur we really
receive in my mind sick mind I think
sometime I wake up like something I wake
up and sometimes I think I'm special
I think I'm especially to my um my pain
my nerves of my back start to hurt I
realize I'm nothing
you know sometimes that that illusion of
myself makes me think I'm something
until something happens to me it's
somebody that I love and then I know any
god is great you know that's that's been
my armor override I don't say we damaged
him like my own around the perception of
myself now you know that everything I
did is just under the mercy of God I was
born and soon I was born mmm I'm gonna
die so it's all right I have to do
something and I did something called the
tote the farm how do you explain the
told the tote is a journey
it's an ancient medicine that they
collect the venom of this toad the
Sonoran Desert toad they collect its
venom and you can smoke it with a shaman
and you experience all sorts of things
in ego death for one you know it
releases you from a lot of pain and
trauma that you've experienced in your
life Mike has done
a handful of times and he's you know
he's for sure
in the last hello we known each other my
two years almost two years
Mike experienced a spiritual awakening
and he's just been you know growing and
evolving ever since in a very positive
way and I mean since he told you that
now though I did too told it I'm I
listen I just can't stop doing cocaine
and licking [ __ ] [ __ ] right I just
can't stop doing this this was before
the day I just can't stop doing that
right is something wrong I just can't
stop doing this [ __ ] right I did the
toilet - you didn't think about the [ __ ]
with me and I'm saying them I said what
is going on why I feel this so I take it
again and then something else at my face
I'm probably what what am i seventy
eight seventy pounds overweight sent of
me hey get in shape it disgusts it look
beautiful be beautiful and then I start
getting in shape all of something I lose
60 70 pounds weight and so it tells me
um you're better than that be a
businessman watch the movie the Baha men
who built America
what's John Deere echo for Cornelius
Vanderbilt watching these guys watch the
mic this thing is telling me that I
don't know no reason right now no just
[ __ ] well I can read real KTM right
but right so um so I watch these guys no
son I'm getting into business I muscle
after this we gettin busy undetermined
that that was what for property owner
and impatient ranch
Who am I am it happened to me I'm not
gonna leave my ship I'm not driving this
[ __ ] car not me I'm not qualified to
drive this console West what's happen in
the ring wait look at me ray my
different funding you prospectus Eve of
me before some it's not for everybody I
have to say like that but um I don't
know what I'm living like this I'm happy
there yeah I'm gonna figure it out you
know I'm gonna figure this out
but this is essence this is going on
this has been awesome this has been
really awesome and stuff
I don't know
I can't know know what to say I don't
know why I don't hang around [ __ ]
ass trifling ass [ __ ] that mone
attracted to people could enhance my
life and he has come in my life I don't
go to like this come visit me you know I
don't know I'm not I want to start
talking scary [ __ ] will let you [ __ ]
but it's just what it is all right
it's just what it is well ray you have a
relationship with God right absolutely
yeah at the core of it medicines like
the toad or ayahuasca have you heard of
ayahuasca no at night these are ancient
tribal medicines and really what they do
is they just put you in touch with God
very bad I don't mean to excuse me but
remember um I saw you last I would
happily they were honoring me with
something yes yes what the [ __ ] did I do
to get on doing anything really
seriously what have I done with then
that was what a couple of weeks ago
within that time what have I done to be
honest I said ring but it's just
happening I don't know what the [ __ ] did
I do it it's been Mike I mean you we
affect people in various ways give them
what is confidence whether it's like you
know like this inspiration but if I
didn't take that tone the way that I was
conducting my father no way would it
dumb given me anything well the crazy
thing no no they would enough though now
me being emeriti being disgusting me
lascivious around peoples women and
stuff note it would enough you're crazy
I'm a [ __ ] codified [ __ ]
[ __ ] when I was a [ __ ] [ __ ] the work
you got like none the six months yeah
three months how long was six six months
ago I become deaf deaf because all this
stuff man any because of who I am
the total see when I when I try to
explain to people people probably think
this guy's
well you've given yourself over to
spirit Mike don't you think not listen
when they told me this stuff I took the
[ __ ] ID I said did this what he told me
when I'm talking
get the [ __ ] out of here [ __ ] I'm not
gonna hear that [ __ ] my math [ __ ]
prove it to me no spooky deal the thing
that matters the most is that Mike is in
the best shape of his life right now
once you say Mike absolutely without
question no psychological spirit yes yes
respect father's my family my wife you
know I mean never cheat on her getting a
little crazy [ __ ] yes that and from that
perspective I have a perspective of mine
ever since I've been chances I've been
everything until recently the toe I
never had a perspective for myself no
perspective that was Mike the champion
all this there was no perspective I just
was existing I didn't know who was just
existing yeah I did not know who I was
yeah all those years did not know who I
was and no self-respect hmm I thought it
was a fine [ __ ] I had no self-respect
you know I I came down to earth many
years ago 15 years ago and because say
for example was a lamp
I'll be sitting here and the lamp is on
as someone said turn the lamp off I mean
the lab is right there I would let's go
way back when I was really in desperate
need of help with the cocaine with the
alcohol I said turn right off turn the
lamp off I mean the lamp is right I
could do that but I was so into me that
it took a while until my wife one day
she said no you turn the damn light lamp
off hmm
I looked at her and I said for a second
I said should I tell her to go to hell
or should I do it I said it's better to
do it and I did it and it it it seems so
simple and and so petty
but it
that was a part of getting my life
together no getting my life together
great one mistake sounds so egotistical
so my megalomania you can't handle your
creepiness person I think that can't
handle it I wonder I told God please
make me somebody I can't handle this man
I have to tell myself that see nasty
things about myself because I got such a
big ego the payment it's about just
something [ __ ] hearing your hearing
your name your [ __ ] it all your time
nothing
they don't they never know what that's
like so here you're naming your head all
the time yeah but I it was painfully it
was paying it was yeah this means pain
and then even think of great the hey
Mike the gym if pain yeah wait cuz what
what happened with me my back in the day
I didn't know really who my friends were
I didn't really know if my family tree
loved me for who I am I just I was so
just fighting mentally sick Allah
psychologically spiritually fighted in
my my my heart my heart was was at risk
now then he lost it but I came back I
came back hey listen right I gotta go
back to the ego I'm sorry but listen
right wait it's only two Sugar Ray's in
existence so many people try it but they
declared out there's only two later
there's only two and I don't think this
would be anymore you're not good yeah
it's a real he's really looking at me
think about Michael it's rare brother
that's what it's only told you out of
all he is a fighting insani to you torn
to you there's only two of you I take
you take that back to your ego
Wow isn't that happy to be you it took a
long time it took a long time to do well
you had to understand it has to be
within you it's crucially within you
because everything become materialistic
it becomes about the dollars this event
until you able to be okay with yourself
be okay with who Reyes who Mike is you
won't live that life I mean no one else
is gonna be okay with you thank you
right yes exactly no one else is gonna
come in and show you how to be Mike it's
okay to be you mike is we're okay with
you that doesn't happen you know we come
from a world even yeah so we come from a
world where we look up to people where
we idolize people yeah whoever the
neighbor the baddest fighter the baddest
drug dealer the baddest killer the bad
is pretty boy whatever we look up to
whatever they have that makes them oh do
we look up to that so we come from a
community a worshipping and want to be
worshipped and they never leave the
stays in us till we die
yeah hey guys I gotta say this I
remember vividly when I was okay in my
own pants I went to a party and for some
reason I didn't dress up or anything
just went straight there got there and I
and I stay for a couple hours and I
enjoyed everyone because normally I go
dressed up and this and that I didn't
need to be all dressed up to to be Rea
it was painful it was scary but I left
that party being Rey I mean I'm sugar
right
but Ray has to at one time step and say
I keep their cool keep that down you
know
come on keep the ego damn and I do that
every day gotta fight of it I decided to
afraid more
every day every time every day I find ya
you destroyed me a destroyed my wife and
my kid they destroy all of us yes kill
us all the willingness s to be to be
humble to be happy oh you want to be
humble you only hope you'll be beaten
into submission you're gonna be humble
before your time is over you're gonna
tell them you're gonna bow so teach you
to you and I bow down at your knees yeah
I'm not a religious guy always use
religious to take advantage of people in
my whole life and thought I did I
thought I was taking advantage of people
and my experience with the totally not
so good and I may have found that
everybody was watching me whenever I did
the people they were watching me mm-hmm
nothing's a secret everything I did that
I'm ashamed of they've been watching me
to be a VIP to be celebrity to be
wealthy to be famous all of us it makes
it so hard hard but it it is extremely
disturbing but when you pass the test is
confident but when you find yourself at
the tip that you normally failed
it's an incredible feel it's incredible
fear rather than having a billion bucks
you know my incredible feeling you can't
imagine that feeling man that thing that
always took me down every time I every
time I cheated I thought I'm a bit do
cocaine I feel like [ __ ] oh why I do the
outs
Oh got a drink oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
and I beat that now and I know listen
you don't beat them cuz you beat them
that day every time he comes up I beat
them every time he's in front of me I
beat them so far
you know this message but we're giving
out is is priceless man I mean people
need to hear that our kids need to hear
this yeah so many lives will be saved
it's many last
will not be destroyed and that's that's
why I'm feeling so great being here man
you know this is this is just real this
is really this is all about improving
yourself there it's just and have to
form human beings half the purity to the
earth proves themselves as human beings
there's so much negativity we could
discourage so much we easy to get
discouraged and that's what happened
with me in your box we've been beaten
even not but we didn't give didn't get
discouraged didn't do the search we
didn't that's why people that don't like
us have to respect us we didn't get
discourage bad people that are tougher
people than us got discouraged but stuff
for you it though
tougher than enough smarter than us but
we're here why do here they should be
here why something that we had I don't
know I'm not telling me you go to school
but I am in the way but you know I'm
saying right yeah they gave up yeah you
guys never gave up you know you still
don't give up on yourselves and after
that ego the [ __ ] am i doing Hannibal oh
yeah they come down to nowhere I mean
look at I'm gonna know both of you guys
finding your best selves after you're in
your late 40s you know so many men are
running around the world right now
thinking their life is over they're in
their mid-40s they haven't accomplished
what they want they're not living the
life they want they're depressed no
listen don't forget though good talk
about that they have everything they
accomplished everything those are the
ones sure get those other guys those
guys are gonna win you know I mean those
guys have people that care about them
they're not pushing them away and all
that stuff those guys got people that
come put them in the rehab imagine a guy
like me [ __ ] you you know who I am yeah
you know when you was in school I
conquered the [ __ ] world of fighting
my big ego how somebody's gonna tell me
no one helped me I did it myself I
didn't do it to my father or my
grandfather I didn't have it [ __ ] how
could somebody talk to me
really how can I talk to you how can
that happen
you gotta be humbled God humbles you
it's almost impossible to wait to
surrender I agree with that yes never
duel and I totally agree with that I
agree yeah surrender in the so
liberating yeah it's the ultimate
liberation all that for fake ego stuff
yeah you know for me I thought that I
knock a holic or child addict or is on
the streets you know hundreds it yeah
and I don't do good [ __ ] yeah therefore
imagining injury I would be doing no I
said my god it took me 2 P years to to
to accept that that you know it doesn't
discriminate alcohol drugs for that but
um
you know man I learned something every
it's this it it made the song said you
can't teach an old dog new tricks that's
not true I don't believe that I don't
believe that I believe it
never ignore [ __ ] I don't
believe that he don't want to learn but
isn't it great guys I mean look at this
I mean look at us the three of us
talking just openly you know without
holding back me because sometimes I'll
say something I've said something and
that's it damn I won't take it back but
no I don't want to you know I don't you
know I don't want to take it no no
because you're not gonna get the full
effect of what you have to express to
whoever you want to express the two of
you pull in the back yeah that's what I
believe yeah absolutely I believe that
Ray do you live in LA I've been in LA
for twenty about 26 years amazing yeah
well you you gotta you're welcome here
any time then man this is any time you
want to come here I know Mike loves that
absolutely today blew my mind I think
I'd never dated that so it's just
how did you wake up this morning Mike
hey first thing I do when I wake up I
never dream anymore this is what I do i
went to bed around 10:40 last night got
a king run from minnesota from the
doctor I went to bed I woke up at six
o'clock six fifteen went on a treadmill
I did the trip if I now I just say
that's a nice night's sleep for you
right yeah and you don't normally do
that no that's a that's a great sleep
rate thing that was great yeah ten forty
great so I did the workout and then we
had to come here so I listened to some
affirmations always listen to
affirmations this is probably gratitude
affirmation thanking God for my eyes my
health my intestines my smile is
everything thinking I'm for everything
that it is anything my ability to think
my ability to earn money residual money
and stuff and then ability to love this
this is my gratitude for everything that
exists for umm then I get up kiss the
kids if they're not going to training
already kiss my wife tell her I love her
I'm sorry but a little fight there last
night and then BOOM I'm off to work yeah
that's you know shower you didn't know
Ray was coming in had no idea I want to
come in today but I said this must I
have to come in when I don't want to
come it that's what I did with training
the day I didn't want to turn out with
the day I trained to spot and that was
my best bar especially when you sports
gotta kicks your ass all the time and
you're going in now come on you don't
wanna come train the next day you wanna
go party
God beat you up everything then you
knock on my one day in the gym
holy moly and your minds I improved
because I never did this to him before I
I know you said they actually they don't
know guys in the jury I want to shoot me
bad in the ring me not in the gym as
hell this guy's in the kidney can't wait
to get in there with you sure yeah three
people to the gymnast she don't fight
she's yes buddies bring them to the gym
[ __ ] the champ watch them beat your ass
you can't beat them in the gym why don't
they and then they fight the money in
the ring and the guy kicks there they
don't even fight nowhere like that the
way they fight you in the gym and the
ring let me say this guy's real quick
you know like last night - I was
watching a couple movies and stuff and
what she'd do because I fall asleep
eventually like 10 o'clock and then
she'll leave going to another room
because I snore and I'll say turn the
lamp on cuz I don't like I don't like
being alone so she Church they show us a
trend little lamp off so she turns the
lamp on cuz I don't like being by myself
well I get this thing feeling I have the
same thing yeah why that's why I did
this fight is just everyone like them or
the entertainer's we also used to being
on people talking about like being
around us because I don't leave why you
got to go big why I gotta go buy me some
food baby huh baby why can't we get
somebody do that for us baby let's get
the main baby let's get two minutes
let's get a butler's baby no but we have
none of that the kids are going to store
picking up food
hey what are you doing - stay with me
baby I can't function then if she
doesn't stay I'm frightened I might say
oh you're going to see baby make her
feel guilty for she stay who are you
gonna see maybe you can't you never
leave you always leave gonna stay this
place must be very important for you to
go to this place because you just always
go so who are you meeting there you
meeting somebody over there and then she
feels good thing she stays and I have to
go I have to play real low together oh
I'm disgusting the cake but it's it's
really much wonderful man why do we do
that but no money freedom I'm Mike I'm
sorry I know we so far we don't wanna be
yeah Calissa no one tells ye to hear our
[ __ ] yeah plain no wants to tell you
yeah you know tell me how great I am
telling great things up
Oh God ain't that from crazy is so crazy
but if they wasn't that way we would
never be here that's something yeah I
would never be if this guy didn't exist
that's how the world works and stuff
yeah you know Harley got me the one
about but he Mandarin made me know this
is what I'm gonna do for the rest of my
life this is what I'm gonna gonna
dedicate my life to doing this mmm
that's just what it was and Mad Men that
I'm just the one tell me man not mean
million the kids all over the world
either fighting and then making them
frightened the witness certain else with
that same ferocious attitude and
competitive spirit that you had and
became successful in business and some
other comers kind of and endeavors and
stuff right
it's beautiful mass really beautiful
it's amazing to have you guys in here
just that's what people for they inspire
everybody everybody's mentor despite
every wasn't him it wouldn't be a lot of
people yeah will not leave there
wouldn't be a lot of people everybody
inspired us what we're all here for to
inspire one another to help each other
because in some weird way we're all
related in a weird weird way I learned
from the tool that we're all one the one
with the trees the rocks the bugs
defecation everything we're all one
yeah it's nothing different all one yeah
ray anything that you want to know what
our audience he'll do it
well this was a special special time I
don't want to say this was an interview
because it it goes beyond an interview
this was from the heart this is from
experience this is from being one of
many and just hope that it uh I've said
something that could that will help you
in some large or small way humility life
got how power
don't ever give up I always say this
that to be a fighter even i'll solder a
because it's gonna take a fight to make
your life right
not less you never give for a fight to
meet you thank you fight the notebook so
take us out Mike go ahead all right well
hey everybody thank you so much for
listening and watching this episode of
hot boxing until next time i'm evan
britain and i'm mike tyson the man Sugar
Ray Leonard your good daddy
thank you brother five-time world
champion six sixes count
who's counting who's counting multiple
world to world champ legendary legend
all right everybody
peace we're out of here
[Music]
[Music]